hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and right now guys i'm doing
youtube videos because i want to pass
the knowledge i want to show you guys
all the different tools and techniques
that i use that work for me
and how to use them yourself so i have
idiot wave principle i have
fib extensions field retracements
magazine moving averages and trend lines
this is my environment guys and i want
you to understand
how i build up my trades so you can do
it yourself so if you want to know about
all the stuff and actually how to make
money on the markets
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to
apply illegal wave theory to amc price
action
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so this is amc i am on the
four hours time frame
for those who have watched my previous
videos i have
actually some bullish targets and i
found my targets using fib extensions if
you want to know how i found it go check
it out on my other videos
but here i'm just going to apply ilya to
a theory and try to see
if a move up is actually making sense
and the target is going to be
actually given by fibs to apply illiot
wave principle you need
to keep in mind that moves up are
developing in five waves
and moves down so one two three four
five and moves down
are developing in three waves corrective
moves
a b c this is the basis
you need to find a starting point so the
starting point is when the trend is
shifting here the trend is going lower
and suddenly we have this breakout
around the the five or six level
and now we are developing higher this is
the perfect situation
to apply idiot with principle one two
three four five
and then correction so a
b c and guys are very important
abc zigzag corrections for the counting
to be correct
you need to have five waves in your
zigzag and here
we have the five waves all right one two
three four five
so this one is a sub wave so i'm just
going to keep it here i just
i wanna make my drawings light so we
have a one
we have a two and now guys we are doing
the third wave and usually the third
wave is the most impulsive so here the
first wave was so impulsive that maybe
it's not going to be more
impulsive on the third wave but maybe it
will but
what i'm just saying is that here we
have a one
two and now we're just in the third wave
of the third wave guys
that will probably go to 20 which was
the maximum level that we had here
then correction and then to 35 all right
so the levels are given
to me by uh fibs all right so very
quickly i'll show you how
i do it submerge the first wave and i
apply it to the bottom of the second
wave
and 35 is my level because it's the
1.618 and surprise
is that the all-time high is 35 all
right funny
so but it's not what i want to discuss
here with you guys
so what i wanted to show you is that we
are only doing the third wave
of the uh move up and of course if it's
really
a move up i mean if it's a motive move
it's going to be one two three four five
so i'm not saying we're going to go to
100
i'm just saying that if we go to 35
trust me the false wave is going to be
very interesting to look at
and if we see some higher highs and
higher lows and
some price action reversals around the
force wave after we went to 35
guys this means that we're gonna go even
higher all right so we're not there yet
i'm gonna keep updating you guys with
all the stuff i'm gonna keep doing
this kind of analysis iliad fibs and
show you guys
what is my view so you can build up your
own view as well
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i see you guys